[Music]
okay it's time to debate movies again
yeah which movie are we talking about
this week Jackie Robinson 142 good know
exactly how I feel about that movie yeah
well I'm going first I don't care how
you felt about it and I think the movie
was good and my first reason is Chadwick
Boseman I think he's the main reason
this movie was good whose Butler is that
he's not a butler he's an actor like
Jackie Robinson's lease types are you
sure you're not a racist like dug deep
it's not bad it's just that I mean I
didn't look at him all that closely to
be honest he's in every single frame of
the movie what were you looking at if
you weren't looking at him other stuff
all right well if you didn't know it
wasn't Wesley Snipes it was in prison
when they shot them by the way but you
definitely don't know whether the
performance was good or bad I'm taking
four that was easy it's mine I'm wanted
on it that's fine that's okay I'm gonna
cut it right back up with my first point
which is the Disney vibe racism why do
you have to keep making up new words why
can't you just use words that are
already you know accepted English
language use there's a ton of them
Disney 5 racism is when they take the
feel-good don't ruffle anybody's
feathers cloth and wipe it vigorously
over any scene that has to do with
racism rendering them basically harmless
you've got the scene where the opposing
manager said the n-word 3,000 times in
the span of about 5 minutes no no it
didn't that's the point that one scene
the movie has the balls to go for yeah
right but every other scene that has to
deal with racism they cop out they take
the soft way out bluntly people called
him names his teammates didn't like him
at first
come on the real Jackie Robinson had to
deal with more than that in just a
single day of his life
all right my turn
Harrison Ford I thought Harrison Ford
was awesome what you didn't like the
horse performance come on you didn't
like him he was so far over the top he
went sliding down there
I did not just say that I know you
didn't just say it have been any more
cartoonish they literally would have had
to call his character burgermeister
meisterburger so a guy has like an
accent and a little bit of a limp and
yes Popeye faces that whole movie come
on now this is not even uppercase
clothes that was taken the point you
can't just say case closed and another
problem I had was a speechifying again
with the speechifying here we go how
many inspirational motivational speeches
do you think the real owner of the
Brooklyn Dodgers gave of real drag your
Amundson in his entire career I'm sure I
have no idea why - sure in this movie
which only covers like two seasons by
the way he gives 27 inspirational
speeches to Jackie Robinson could call
this movie Lincoln to the baseball tears
yeah with a hundred and thirtysomething
year-old Lincoln that makes a lot of
Harrison Ford's just about old enough to
play and unassessed and it did like oh
come on now he's only 70 years old did
you know that Lincoln was assassinated
on Jackie Robinson Day oh it wasn't
Jackie Robinson day at the time but the
same day April 15th don't you think
that's kind of kooky maybe we should
just call it a day there man I mean the
only problem I had with the film is a
little racist boy in the audience who
hears his dad say the n-word and so he
says it too right in the cheesiest scene
since the ending of the postman I mean
another problem is Sammy Sosa has a
cameo in this movie in the Stan's
what like 85% sure it was him why would
they give Sammy Sosa a cameo in this
movie because he played baseball
so did Cal Ripken yeah but he's not
african-american
neither is Sammy Sosa now who's an idiot
you the answer to that question is
always going to be used Sammy Sosa is
Dominican
so he's African Dominican wow they are
really gonna call you racist after this
video no he's from the Dominican
Republic it's a country is anything like
the Banana Republic yes it's right next
door well then I know where that is
you might know the store on the other
side too it's called no to Republic yeah
what are they so stamps